Ahh fucking! God damn it!
Hi! How you doing?
Good to see you here!
I uh....
Didn't notice you there at first.
But I just wanted to say...
Thanks for stopping by!
I'm not quite done farming yet.
But I'll be with you in just a moment.
You can watch while I work you...
Beautiful people!
And uh, totally ignore the fact that I just got spooked
By uh...Warpstache over there
Hey buddy. How are you doin'?
Seems like every time I say the word, "Warpstache"
You pop in and out of existence Like an...
A-hole!
That's a lot of salt.
Much like this guy's got a lot of salt!
About his... d-dumbness!
Heh!
Got him!
Roasted him good!
Oh are they?
These are wonderfully charged.
I do appreciate you, being so studious in their, level of chaaarge.
Those are doing... whooooa!
Those are doing well
Let me.. I'll leave that one in
Ah boink!
Ah boink
And um
No, that's good! 891! Very good.
I know mmmm..
I am delightful!
Alright, who is my Silver!
You are my Quartz
Give you de Quartz
Oh! FULL of Quartz!
Heck-a yeah-ah.
Man that un. That unlimited energy thing is...
That's real handy that is!
I am not gonna lie.
I am.. Totally okay with doing that
100% Because... My God that makes my life easy.
Where oh where... Is there more Silvah?
Ye oh!
I SEE YOU BELOW ME!
Whoa!
Hey!
How you doing there friendo!
Didn't know that this was your territory.
Hope you don't mind if you uh...
Fuck off and die...
That's an option.
Just wanted to throw that out there.
You're not gonna stop me from gettin' my silver!
Not today...
(musicalish) Not todaaayeah.
Yeah try and get me! Try!
Big Box Berry is gonna fffudge you up!
Mother Humper!
I showed him!
Whoa hey!
(Leviathan noise) Mark:  Whoahoo
Alright then that was close for comfort.
I don't feel safe..
And many of you may know whether I'm actually in danger or not but...
He doesn't seem too interested.
Alright, well alright I'm gonna go for it.
Hey! Come at me bro! Come at me...Don't come at me! Do NOT come at me!
Ooohhhh! Don't come at me... Lil more! x3
Ohhh that's close for comfort...okie.....I'M GONNA GO!!!
I'M GONNA GO NOW
Oh fuck I missed!
Well.....That was close!
I think some how got outta that by the skin of my tits......Ahhh! My razor steel nips!
Well I think I screamed like a lil baby, but that's okay! Because....
You know...
Happens. (Sniff) Anyway...
I almost cried, but that's all good
Maybe I can ram him.
It doesn't seem like the Cyclops gets any...
Dents anymore
Well, there's more silver, but again I don't know if that's safe for me to get.
Maybe if I stay within the- aw that that one looks- that one looks much more friendly to get.
That one looks /much/ friendlier.
Alright! I likey this one.
This one's A+ in my book.
Now let's hope I don't diiiee!
Oh, hey. Here we go.
Weeeh
Okay. Seems safe? Question mark?
Alright. Here we go.
Silver, silver silver! I love lots of sii-iilver!
Silver, silver, silver! Uh hope I don't die now!
Silver, silver, silver! GET IN MY BODY!
Uuh silver. I love you.
Silver, silver, silver. Open up your door now!
Silver, silver, silver. Charge up my (unintelligible)
Silver, silver, silver. I WISH I WERE DEAD NOW!
I weren't dead. Not- Not I wish I were dead. Tha- That'd be sad.
Silver, silver, silver. Oh fill up your baby
Mm, Fuck yeah.
Okay! Welcome back to Subnautica.
Sorry about the slightly jarring opening, but I am now ready to go towards this precursor cache
And not only that, I know exactly where it is and I know exactly how to find it.
But first, CorkyLoo, who said 'So if Mark's children Jeffery, Billy, Samwise, and Marshal
Made Big Box Barry, and then Big Box Barry and the Reefback made Jeremy or Blaslsaglsl or whatever his name is,
Does that mean Mark is a Great-Grandfather?'
YAY! CONGRATS MARK!
I suppose that does?
Oddly enough
It adds a little bit of incestuous connotations with it, with Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshal
But I'mmona overlook that considering there's absolutely no one else here,
And they're all robots anyways, so it's all just...
I can overlook that.
Love is love.
And then, uh, Pokemaniac Chris who said:
'Is it just me who wants Mark to scan the Reaper Leviathan?'
(Deep breath)
It's a sadistic thing that you want.
I can try. I'll try for you.
I- I legitimately will try to scan
The Reaper Leviathan.
I'm not even going to put it off. I'm gonna do it as soon as I get done with these comments.
But you may be looking like 'Oh! Only two lockers this time, Mark?!'
'What-What's goin on? It's normally three!'
Oh! Hold your horses.
I've got another locker over here in the 'naughty' corner. And you can see it right there.
And, you should know that this person deserves this.
UHM! MISTER CONMASTER1012!
WHAT WERE YOU EVEN THINKING?!
I should have known by your name that you were up to no good.
And I'm not talking Marauder's Map no good
I'm talking like...
Blow up the Aurora and destroy all my friends and family no good.
You said:
'You should name your Seamoth Puny Package Patty'
Well HOW DARE YOU!
MR. OR MRS. I DON'T REALLY KNOW AND I DON'T WANT TO ASSUME ANYTHING CONMASTER!
HOW COULD YOU!
Think about what you've done in your corner as I try to scan a Reaper Leviathan.
Which is probably a bad idea
But then again I've had bad ideas before and this probably won't be the last.
So,  you think about what you dou have done.
As I rush off to meet certain doom at the hands of this particular Reap-
I'm coming for youu!
Hey! You wanna- you wanna- you wanna dosey-doe buddy?
You wanna dosey-doe? BONK!
Oh ho ho! Get rekt biatch!
Hey, where'd yo go man? Where'd you go?
Reapey?
Reaper Leviathan?
Reaper?
He was just here. I was gonna knock it. You know, give it a little love nudge...
With my Big Box Barry, here, but it seems to have...
Skedaddled? It didn't just disappear does it?
Where the heck? It just disappeared!
Did the Warper warp it awaay?
Can it do that?
Well that's pecu- oh hey.
Hey, you wanna play another game of chicken there, buddy?
Uh! Come on! What you got? Uh! What's that?
'Oh no, don't hit me with your Big Box Barry! Oh no!'
Well, I guess that's not a problem.
Oh, ha ha.
I don't see him anymore. He seems to be gone.
Let me just go get piece of titanium 'cause I want it.
Alright. Don't see it!
Very scary that I don't see it!
Just gonna get this other piece of titanium alone in the ocean.
Not scared at all!
Alrighty thennn-ugh
I though I was gonna try to scan a Reaper Leviathan, but that doesn't seem to be in the cards.
So, I found out how to do the coordinates thing.
So the coordinates to the dunes alien precursor cache is
-1187, -378 and 1130
Which all count to X, Y, and Z coordinates
So, one being the depth down, one being lateral, one being longitudinal
Uh, and you find your coordinate by pressing F1
And that'll bring up this debug menu, not a cheat menu.
Uh, it'll bring up a menu that'll allow you to know
Where your position is if you look at the camera world position somewhere in the upper middle area that
You'll see... a set of three numbers.
So, I'm looking for 1187 on the first one,
Which means I'm pretty close to that.
I just gotta go this way a bit
And then
378, which I'm assuming means 378 down
And then 1130
So that's the distance that I've got to travel the most
Which is forward.
And I'm thinking that it's on the other side of this...
Like...
Mushroom Forest
It said it was in a crater.
Now... if I think back I think I remember seeing a crater...
Somewhere here, so I'mma take that information, and I'm going to...
Go to where I think the crater is
'Cause there's an entrance to the inactive lava zone here.
But there's also a crater that I found a long time ago.
That didn't didn't seem to do anything.
Now, if that's the one they're talking about, that means...
They put something new there
And that I can find it, because I've got a purple alien key.
And I'mmona stick it in any purple slot that I see
Sorry
Okay, so headed down a bit
Just a- just a- just a squeeze
Just a squeeze
'Cause I gotta get down to -378
So this must go down at some point and it looks like that point is noow
Whoo, this is the void, isn't it?
Whoo, this is- this is quite a void
The sun is setting. Oh, I couldn't tell.
Oh, there we go! Well, that came out of nowhere.
Oh, is this- is this it, actually?
Or is this just the edge of... everything? That I know. And love. And care about
'Cause I can't see shit except for something glowing over there.
I don't know what that is
What the heck are you?
OH!
OOOH!
OOOOOOOH!
That looks like an entrance...
To some sort of Precursor thiiing!
OOOH SHNAP!
I CAN'T SEE JACK SHIT
But I can see you.
Okay, so I'mmona nestle-
Nestle mah Big Box Barry...
Right next to this ominous looking cave that looks like a mouth with teeth in it
And I'mmona save, and then I'mmona eat some fruit!
And then I'mmona get the fudge outta here.
Don't worry, I just did that to scare off the predators
Loud noises do that or whatever I- probably- I don't know
Nom nom nom
Okay, that'll be enough for now, and then I've got some water over here.
Just (gulp) okay.
"Warning: Blood Loss Detected" I JUST DRANK WATER!
What is your problem?
Okay, I'm gonna put this away, here.
DOINK, DOINK!
Uh, I don't need the silver with me, but I want to keep it with me just 'cause I feel like it, okay?
Alright, whatever. Yeah
YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT YOU'VE DONE, CONMASTER!
So, should I take my Sea-clops or should just go in hand and foot?
I gue- I guess I can take this
Hah! Come- give it to me! Uh! Shove me right in there! Up through the butthole
I'm gonna take Mr. Fister, but I'monna abandon him as soon as I can
Because I just don't wanna deal with his bullshit
"Welcome aboard, Captain!" Thanks
Whoo.
Oh, this is weird
Okay. Fadoosh! Brooski! Okay!
Uuh, Alright here.
Okay. I'll grab some acid mushrooms on the way out because I need a drug trip in addition to what the hellhole I'm going into.
Do I hear the ethereal glowing of a door?
Oh, I doo.
Oh, is that a purple slot? I'mmona shove something in there.
I got you covered buddy!
hAFOOSH YEAH TAKE THAT!
Rewind it back.
I got the beat to make 'er booty go smack, whatever it is.
Aah that's a Reaper.
Oh right you can't get me in this caaaave, buddy-boo.
I can barely fit in this cave...
Well, maybe I can't go any further-
yES I CA- Ah shoot.
Okay. Can't go any further than this
so... I hope there's a.
Woooooooah, what is this?
Oh, okay. Oh, uh. Ion crystals.
Thank you!
Thank you untold energy in the palm of my hand, huh?
Woah...
Gimmie your data.
'Alien Biological History' unlocked!
Well good!
Cool! I think anyway.
Well, nom nom nom nom nom, nom.
Okay.
Alright, I guess that's all I needed. Holy hell.
Four Ion Crystals?
Was that it?
I mean let me look at the data first, before I just
like (mumbles) data.
Alright.
That guy is angry up there.
sTOP HUMPIN' BIG BOX BARRY!
HE'S TAKEN!
"Was grown from seed 1,708 Earth years ago."
"Separated from broodlings early for special training."
"Inducted into temple of research as the youngest ever initiate, age 96."
"Downloaded a corrupt dataset and was stored for 3 years for refactoring."
"Relocated to the outer galaxy cluster to support disease research endeavors."
"Relocated to 4546B for high priority disease research."
"Contracted carar bacterium."
"Stored in Sanctuary 3, corporeal body safely disposed."
That's interesting.
Grown from seed... Separated from broodlings for early training...
So this is talking about one
of the Precursers.
And there's interesting stuff here because obviously
their brains work
in the way computers do...
In that it can download data and
it downloaded a corrupted dataset.
But their physical bodies are still...
...biological in...
...design, I guess.
So it's either a hybrid of...
Yeeash.
It's either a hybrid...
Oh no.
Oh, that's the way I was supposed to go- whoops.
It's either a hybrid of some sort.
Or it's technology develop- like developed to the point where,
Something can...
Y'know, just interface with the brain and
they can download information as they wish.
Which is cool.. But that.
That raises so many more questions.
That gives some interesting like- information.
Oh hey sorry.
Okay. I'll skedaddle.
I want the safety of Big Box Barry's bosoms
Give it to meeeee, okay.
But that also raises some interesting questions
as to whooo...
...these aliens are.
What does that.. mean for, like the entirety of their society
if their children or their useful tools
are grown...
From seed in big batches and relocated as needed.
Do they have free will? Is this like a thing where it's just-
"Hey, do what your told until you die and then your body is disposed"?
But then it said "corporeal body" which I- I'm pretty sure that means...
...the physical body.
But maybe the consciousness was downloaded or uploaded into the-
the computer system.
A-this is facinating. It was stored for 8 yaers
and obviously these things have long life-spans
if the earliest initiative was 96 Earth-years old.
And considering, this was 1700 years ago
that it was born, or grown from seed...
Then that could mean that-
it contracted carar only recently.
And that would be very interesting-
okai, hello.
But either way, I did what I accom- I set out to accomplish
which is good. Because I have silver.
And I have quartz, and I've got a lot- a lot of materials to work with here.
The only thing I don't have is a lot of titanium, but I can grab that on the way back.
Now I need to go back to my main base down below because now,
I have enough material.
And I have my kitty poster to keep me company.
But I have enough material to go deep down in.
To the Inactive Lava Zone and see,
what really lies
down in the deep heart of the ocean
that terrifies me so.
And I'm pretty sure I can fit my
Big Box Barry down the way in the-
the- the Grand Reef but uh, I'm not a 100% sure
so this might be a wild adventure where I try to squeeze Big Box Barry
in holes he shouldn't fit in
ugh...
But,
I'm gonna try my best and see where that gets me from here.
Too bad I couldn't scan that Reaper Leviathan, y'know.
I'm really broken up about that.
oH WELL.
C'est la vie!
Ooooh! Copper!
Ah silver, I've got enough of you.
But I need me some copper.
I need me some strength, silver, you understand.
I- I'm a Roman
I'm a Roman sole survivor of a wreck and I have no actual friends
So I gotta personify a giant mineral
Or an element.
Ah, who cares what you are, but copper's where it's at, baby.
Copper's where it's hot.
It just- It just get's me you know.
I can poon it whenever I want.
Harpoon, I mean, yeah.
You know what I'm talking about, right?
What?
I don't know. I'm tryna create a love triangle with silver and copper and...
I think I'm going crazy.
I- I think I might actually be going crazy.
Yeah I'm pretty sure I'm going crazy.
Yeah 100- I'm going crazy, yeah.
Alright, so now, what I need to do is I need to get back to my base.
And uh... maybe drop off some of this stuff.
Copper and such in there.
Silver's starting to stack up, sowasread you're so was Silver now and
Just a little bit of Ion Crystal. How about that, yeah.
Alright, so I need some Table Coral
Before I go all the way back, I need to cut up a bunch of Table Coral.
And then I should be good to go down and I don't think...
I don't think I'm gonna need any more...
Materials
To get what I need to get to be able to get where I need to go.
I'm pretty sure
Not 100%
Not 100%, but pretty sure.
I think.
Maybe
Not 100%
Ooh, more titanium.
Well there's- there's noormal coral.
I can at least get some of that so I can make some more water.
I don't know why I spent so much time, like, building a water filtration thing that drains a million tons of power.
When I could literally take common coral all day long
And then get all the possible water I need out of all the salt I have
Which salt is so plentiful,  why would I even bother trying to go anywhere else for it.
Okay. So I'm literally just going to carry a whole mess of this common coral
And then get table coral as I go and then live my life, you know?
Just be free.
Feel the world around me.
Just feel it.
I've been in the ocean long enough that I've started to realize that
Maybe we're not so different after all.
Maybe I shouldn't have been so scared.
Maybe... Just maybe...
This ocean loves me and wants to accept me as who I am.
And you know... maybe...
Just maybe
If I find solace in the fact that...
We're not so different.
Maybe I can learn to love it.
Maybe I can even learn to respect it, you know?
Maybe there's something to be said about that.
Aaalright. That's a little bettahr.
Now we're starting to stock up. I'm starting to actually use these lockers, which is something that I...
Never really did before.
Ok, so the last thing that I need, before I leave this episode is that I need to find me some table coral
'Cause once I got that...
There's no stopping me.
I've got everything I could possible hope for.
And this looks like where there would be table coral, but it's not there...
It's peculiar.
Wheare's the table coral?
Where are you?
Where are all of you?
Where you hide from me?
I'll kill each and every one of you.
I'll kill your whole family.
I'll kill all your coral mates.
I'll kill them all!
And you ain't never gonna see it comin'.
Ah, you ain't never gonna see it comin' eh?
Ah.
You though you could escape?
Huh?
You thought you could run?
Nah.
Not from me.
Not for long.
Ah always get me prey.
Speakin' of prey....
I'm gonna pray for more power.
'Cause that's what ah need.
There's gotta be some table coral aroun-
I SEE YOU! OH I STRUCK THE MOTHERLODE!
I struck it. I struck that motherlode.
I'mmona take all of you.
I'm never gonna run out of coral again.
As I scream into the distance: CORAL!
I know
I know.
I know. Shh. Hush now. It's okay.
You're home.
You're home with me.
That is... a lot of table coral.
I'mma still get more, 'cause I got space to fill in my inventory.
And I've got space to fill in my Big Box Barry.
Oh, yes.
OH YES!
Oh, yes. I'm. Good.
OOH YES!
Alright, Kachiro, you're gonna get a whole bunch of table coral
But I'mma keep some of you because I'm about to make some stuff.
And I need you to be right here with me.
BY MY SIDE!
WHERE'S ALL MY SILVER AT?
There you are.
Though you could hide from me? Nah.
Nah, you can't.
'Cause I'm about to make...
Wiring kit. Oh I do need quartz.
OOPSIES!
Oh, yes.
Computer chip. Finally.
I knew.
I knew
I knew you wouldn't run from me this time.
Alright, so what do I need to make that other battery charger?
Titanium and then for the other one, copper wire.
Where did I put that copper?
I DON'T KNOW WHERE ANYTHING IS HERE!
Alright, so can I another- yes I can.
Okay, so that means I've got two computer chips.
And now I just need a wiring kit.
And so, with that...
I've got everything I need to make a second one of those battery charger
And the only benefit to this is that it allows me to charge twice, you know, at a time.
Aaand I'll make that low low low.
(Mark singing sped up.)
Okay I'mma take that back here.
Wait. Now we're gonna redo this. I'm gonna pull a mulligan on this one
Just gonna make it a lil- little higher- little higher. There.
That's- That's the stuff. That's the stuff.
So now that I've got that. Put those bad boys in there.
And then, those bad boys are gonna be charging up all day long.
There gonna nothing stop me.
And also, I think I can make
Oh, the glass! Forgot about the glass.
And just like that... SHAAAAABOOSKI.
Now this one is not self-sustaining.
It's not the same as the power cell ones.
It is going to take a lot more power.
But, the benefit of this is...
I will have a battery charger here, so that I don't have to be constantly making them.
If I wanted to, I could take my Seamoth and grab all the dead batteries from my  uh other base way over yonder way.
But, at least I have it.
Don't mind that it's pitch black, which is kinda- kinda odd.
But I don't mind. Looks stealthy. I like it.
So, with that being said, I am all out of time for this episode.
I can make my way back to my base in the Grand Reef and then venture down deep...
Into the Inactive Lava Zone. Go down the Ghost River
The Lost River. Might as well be the Ghost River.
And see...
What finally lies down lurking deep below.
I'm having a lot of fun this.
I love taking my time and exploring and...
You know, guiding you through this as...
I play through the game and it's just a lot of fun to be able to do this and see the secrets that the developers have made for this game
And it, you know it feels almost real.
I get emotional about this game.
It's become such a big part of what I do that, you know, I can't imagine leaving this ocean now.
Even though it terrifies the crap out of me.
(softer) I still like it. It's good stuff
(normal) So anyway thank you everybody so much for watching.
Hope you enjoyed this. I'll be back very soon so...
Thanks again for watching.
(louder) And as always I will see you... in the next video.
Buh-bye!
*Outro music*